The final thing you'll want to do to
secure the authentication process
is to disable the password base logins.
This will force all of your users to
only be able to login using a key pair.
To do this, you'll have to edit
the configuration file for SSHD.
Which is the service that's running
on the server listening for
all of your SSH connections.
This configuration file is
located at etc/ssh/sshd_config.
And you can edit it using sudo nano.
There are a lot of options in here, and
you can read through them all to get
a better understanding of
how SSH is configured.
The comment lines start
with the hash symbol here.
And they're pretty good at
explaining what everything does.
The line we're looking for is right
here, PasswordAuthentication yes.
We just want to change that to no,
and then we'll save the file.
Now, the SSHD service is
currently running, and
it only reads its configuration file
when it's initially started up.
So we need to restart the service so
it runs with the new configuration
option we just made.
We restart the service by
sudo service ssh restart and
that's all there is to it.
Now all users will be forced
to log in using a key pair.
SSH will not allow users to log in with
a user name and password any longer.